what's going on theo this is billy
marshall out of delray beach florida
billy marshall and man i fell in love
one time with a girl from delray beach
and
i met her on enter on twitter and we
texted and sexed it and everything
sent drawings on my dick and everything
to her and she would
you know you know tell me what her
breasts felt like and everything and
describe it and send me
you know little envelopes and stuff like
that with perfume on the cotton and all
of that
but um
and we texted for months and months and
months and finally we saw each other and
we just it was just it was bafflingly
bad
we could not get along for [ __ ] so
anyway omar brother and uh
today was one of the craziest days i
ever had at work
i started working at this pest control
company in
february okay pest control
and we need it man i'd love to see a
real you know
a real little rodeo man out there just
corralling roaches
you know somebody on a quidditch broom
just chasing a bunch of bees trying to
get them bastards to chill out
trying to keep them away from a picnic
we need pest control we need somebody
out there wrangling these
thoughts out there you know v
g you know corralling these [ __ ] into
an urban outfitters or something
and helping keep the world tight onward
and uh today they they're like all right
go out to the property and
go around the buildings and put your rat
baits out the contract with lumatrak if
you
know what that is oh yeah man killing
rats bro and it's
when you come to the rat king you
talking about killing rats man you got a
lot of
uh nerve but i respect your position
onward you're in post control but
anyways i'm doing the box
and after i do the box i look up and i
see 10
sharpshooters looking right at me with
the rifles like aimed right at me i was
like
i like looked at him i said what and
they said they waved me over i walked
over to him they said this the bomb in
that building
and i i changed the beat wall the bomb
the bomb didn't end up going off but the
bomb squad was there
and i changed the bait and then the bomb
squad got me but man
that's one of those things too i was
high on marijuana like that's
that was an interesting experience high
on marijuana and there we go right there
and that's the truth of it all is that
pot can be a gateway drug man to
bombings
you do a little weed and somebody blows
up your [ __ ] cousin bro
you know you get high and suddenly you
think they got a you know
somebody taped a bunch of c4 up under
your silverado
so it's i've been high enough where i
feel like somebody's trying to bomb me
but
to just be high and then they and
there's real bombs
that's some [ __ ] that's some that's
awesome dude
dude i remember the drug dogs would come
to school
and they would come smell everybody in
the class and they said they were
smelling if you had any weed on you they
would know
and i remember raising my hand and i
said well what if you're just high
will they know that and uh
and the teacher and the police officers
were were not happy about that
because i didn't have any weed on me bro
but i had that [ __ ] in my brain
you know that good evening good
afternoon and
other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could watch this one or watch
this one watch this one watch this one
watches one ah